vous êtes étudiants et vous souhaitez
poursuivre vos études supérieures en
métropole dans cet épisode vous allez
découvrir qu'il existe des dispositifs
mis en place par le département pour
vous soutenir dans votre projet vous
voulez en savoir plus alors suivez-moi
[Musique]
nous sommes à Saint-Gilles et nous
allons à la rencontre de Mehdi étudiant
en double master mathématiques
informatiques à Paris avec l'aide du
département il a pu avoir sa place à la
Cité internationale universitaire de
Paris la CIUP un campus unique qui
accueille de nombreuses étudiants de
plus de 125 nationalités bonjour Mehdi
bonjour Alexandre alors parlez-nous de
votre expérience à la CI up écoutez
maintenant ça va faire bientôt trois
années parce que je suis à la Cité
Universitaire de Paris
il faut dire que c'est un lieu consacré
dédié même à la réussite de nos études
de haut niveau et honnêtement si c'est
en super bien on a une bibliothèque déjà
ça c'est formidable d'avoir une
bibliothèque à moins de 5 minutes de
chiffre de chez soi on a même une
piscine qui à l'intérieur de la maison
internationale on a des cours de tennis
on a des on a des terrains de football
de basket de basket aussi Jean de
l'accueille parce que du coup on les
croise tous les jours ils sont fabuleux
genre on discuté avec eux ils sont
vraiment très proches en tout à la
Maison du Cambodge mais de manière
générale au top là dessus tu es en train
de sécurité est-ce qu'on s'y sent bien
aussi d'ailleurs c'est bien d'avoir
apporté voilà sécurité elle est vraiment
présente vraiment sans eux je pense que
la cité le paillarde du tout plus le
même visage quoi si on revient sur les
échanges avec les étudiants ils sont
nombreux autour de vous comment se
passent les échanges pas les échanges se
font dans tout dans n'importe quelle
langue anglaise français c'est clair que
bon on échange c'est vrai que on peut
les rencontrer dans la cuisine on a des
sorties il y a vraiment des démarches
aussi des démarches dans le but de créer
des projets en commun c'est top quoi de
vivre dans ce petit milieu dans son
petit cocon quoi tes parents un peu de
vous au niveau des études que vous
effectuez sur Paris qu'elles sont-elles
et surtout est-ce que vous êtes loin de
votre établissement alors en terme
d'étude je suis en train de préparer mon
double master en mathématiques
informatiques avec une option
cryptologie en terme de localisation bon
bah ma fac elle est dans le 13e la cité
universitaire elle elle est dans le sud
de Paris mais à l'intérieur de Paris et
en soi c'est très bien des services
c'est top merci Mehdi je vous en prie
par exemple
le Département soutient la réussite
éducative des étudiants réunionnais les
dispositifs départementaux la bourse
l'aide au frais de scolarité et
l'hébergement d'étudiants réunionnais à
la Cité internationale universitaire de
Paris ont ainsi été mis en place afin de
faciliter la poursuite des études
supérieures de nos jeunes en mobilité
bonjour minatte bonjour Alexandre alors
qu'est-ce que la Cité internationale
universitaire de Paris et qui peut lui
prétendre la sérénité c'est un ensemble
de logements réservé aux étudiants de
niveau bac + 4 minimum et inscrit dans
un établissement d'enseignement
supérieur ou dans une université
relevant des académies de Paris Créteil
oversize et combien de logements sont
attribués au département de La Réunion
alors le département disposent de 85
logements réservés aux étudiants
réunionnais dans le 14e et le 19e
arrondissement de Paris donc on dispose
de plusieurs maisons à savoir la Maison
des étudiants de la Francophonie la
maison des provinces de France la maison
du Cambodge et la résidence lilas le
loyer varie environ entre 450 et 600
euros par étudiants alors dites nous
comment peut-on bénéficier d'un de ces
logements alors pour obtenir un logement
il suffit de constituer un dossier sur
le site netbourse et cocher l'option
cuit les inscriptions se déroulent du 30
avril au 15 juin c'est bien merci
Alexandre
là c'est IP est un lieu convivial et sur
qui accueille plus de 12000 étudiants
venus du monde entier les possibilités
de rencontre et d'échanges sont
nombreuses cela n'empêche pas nos
étudiants réunionnais de se retrouver
entre eux très vite pour partager leurs
expériences
faut retrouver toutes les informations
concernant la Cup n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet du
département il s'affiche ici en bas de
votre écran voilà le département des
générations c'est fini vous pouvez
revoir cet épisode et les précédents en
replay sur nos sites et réseaux sociaux
je vous donne rendez-vous très vite pour
un nouvel épisode à bientôt
[Musique]